this video was made possible by
brilliant learn with brilliant for 20%
off by being one of the first two
hundred to sign up at brilliant org
slash win over the purpose of the Panama
Canal is pretty easy to understand it
turns a journey of this into this it
brings the u.s. west coast closer to
Europe and it brings the u.s. East Coast
closer to Asia these rather short 180
foot or 55 meter wide trenches are
combined perhaps the single most
important and most influential waterway
on earth that's because the entire
shipping industry worldwide is shaped by
the Panama Canal hundreds of years ago
the opportunity of a canal across the
narrow country of Panama was identified
after a few earlier false starts the
Americans went down to Panama in 1903
signed a fairly dubious treaty granting
them land dammed up a river to make an
artificial lake dug a trench from that
lake to the Pacific dug a trench from
that lake to the Atlantic and thirteen
billion dollars and 5,600 worker
fatalities later the canal was done it
officially opened the Pacific to the
Atlantic on August 15 1914 as the first
commercial ship the SS n Conn sailed
through now the Panama Canal is not just
one straight shot from ocean to ocean
that's because the artificial lake they
created Gatun Lake is 85 feet or 26
metres above sea level so cargo ships
which can weigh more than a billion
pounds need to get up those 85 feet or
26 metres and then back down again to
transit from ocean to ocean like most
canals to do this the Panama Canal uses
locks from the Atlantic side for example
a ship will be pulled into the first
lock by the tug trains on each side of
the canal the downstream gate will close
water from upstream will be fed in to
fill the lock the boat will float up
then once the water level rises to match
that of the next lock the gate will open
and the ship will be pulled into the
next lock then the gates will close the
water level will rise again the gates
will open then this will all happen one
more time until the third lock raises
the ship to the water level of Gavin
Lake there was 85 feet or 26 metres
above sea level
believe it or not it is these three
locks exclusively that limit what size a
large portion of the world's container
ship fleet can be a ship has to be under
1,200 feet or 366 meters long and
168 feet or 51 meters wide to be
accepted in the Panama Canal and so a
huge proportion of the world ships are
built to be exactly this size this class
of ship is called neo Panamax or new
Panamax
or post-panamax depending on who you ask
of course there are certainly ships
larger than the Neo Panamax size the
Panama Canal has a size limit of about
15,000 teu or twenty-foot equivalent
units that's a measure of a ship's
capacity based off how many of these
20-foot containers they could carry now
the largest container ship in existence
the ooc L Hong Kong has a capacity of
over 21,000 tu this ship like many of
those larger than 15,000 to you
exclusively keeps to the East Asia to
Europe route as it can't efficiently
make trips that require transit between
the Pacific and Atlantic since it would
have to circumnavigate South America but
it was really not long ago that the
larger ships that could go through the
Panama Canal were far smaller than the
current 15,000 teu size you see up until
2016 the Panama Canal could only fit
ships smaller than 5,000 teu that's
because up until 2016 these didn't exist
the Panama canal's new locks the old
locks can only fit a ship 106 feet or 32
metres wide
but still given the enormous importance
of this waterway ships were still then
built specifically to fit through in
fact 50% of the old Blanc's users were
exactly as wide as this with limit
suggesting they were likely built for
exactly that purpose this was a problem
for the Panama Canal though because
believe it or not the canal has
competitors it all has to do with
geography when traveling from East Asia
to the US East Coast which is one of the
busiest shipping routes in the world it
really is not all that much further to
go west than East going from Hong Kong
to Newark for example the distance
heading west through the Indian Ocean
Suez Canal Mediterranean and Atlantic is
only a few hundred miles or kilometers
longer than going east across the
Pacific and through the Panama Canal
meanwhile the Panama Canal is not cheap
they charge a $90 toll per 20-foot
container meaning that most ships
carrying thousands of loaded containers
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
just a single transit with the new locks
and their higher capacity single ships
can possibly be assessed more than 1
million dollars per transit if they're
the largest size fully loaded the Suez
Canal meanwhile typically charges lower
tolls a ship's hailing that Hong Kong to
Newark route therefore might choose to
take the slightly longer route via the
Suez Canal versus the Panama Canal as in
the end when you consider the tolls it
might end up being less expensive
now both canals are constantly changing
their fees in order to compete with the
other but still throughout the past
decade the Suez Canal seems to maintain
a slight edge in cost the Panama canal's
other competitor though is trains for
the crucial East Asia to u.s. East Coast
route going through the Panama Canal
while much faster than circumnavigating
the continent is still not a direct
route on the Hong Kong to Newark route a
Panama Canal represents an almost 3,000
mile or 5,000 kilometre diversion from
the alternative crossing the US by land
it is pretty standard practice to ship
cargo from East Asia to Los Angeles and
then loaded up on trains to get it to
the US East Coast while overall this
usually ends up a little more expensive
than going through the Panama Canal it
saves about a week in transit time and
for many shippers this is worth it
trains with their relatively low cost
represent a considerable competitor to
the canal and it is the competition with
these and the Suez Canal that push the
Panama Canal to make an expansion that's
why they spent 5.4 billion dollars to
build these bigger locks that could fit
larger 15,000 TEU ships this would let
more of the world's shipping fleet
through and these bigger ships thanks to
economies of scale have lower cost per
container which helps make the canal
more attractive in comparison to its
trains or Suez competition now this
expansion is a great example of the
butterfly effect
in one instance because the Panama Canal
widen its size limits by a few dozen
feet the state of New Jersey had to
spend 1.7 billion dollars to raise a
bridge by a few dozen feet you see in
order to get to much of the port of
Newark which is one of the largest and
busiest in the US ships have to pass
under the Bayonne Bridge is a chute
proportion of the shipping traffic to
the US
eastcoast go through the Panama Canal
before the new set of locks many of the
ships that wanted to use the ports of
Newark were the smallest size which
could all fit under the Bayonne Bridge
sitting at 151 feet or 46 meters above
the water with the Canal expansion
project though more ships would start
making their way to Newark that would be
too large to fit under the Bayonne
Bridge therefore in order for the Port
of New York to stay competitive they
just had to raise that bridge beyond
that all up and down the US East Coast
from Miami to Savannah to Charleston to
Baltimore and to New York ports quickly
spent millions and billions of dollars
to build facilities that would fit the
bigger ships in time for the opening of
the new canal locks still today though
many ports on the East Coast do not have
the depth and facilities needed to
handle these neo Panamax ships this
though presents an opportunity for the
Caribbean deepwater ports in the
Caribbean are developing themselves into
major transshipment hubs what these are
are ports where larger ships like the
largest 15,000 tu container ships that
can now go through the canal will unload
their cargo which will then be loaded
again onto smaller ships bound for
smaller ports closer to the cargos
destination up and down the East Coast
huge amounts of foreign money are
flowing into the Caribbean to develop
these transshipment hubs cma cgm a
shipping company from france that ranks
as the world's third largest operation
port of kingston jamaica DP world from
the UAE operates the port of casado in
the dominican republic
meanwhile the port of Freeport in the
Bahamas is operated by Hutchison port
holdings from Hong Kong all of these
companies and more have and continue to
focus on expanding these Caribbean ports
to suit the increased traffic making its
way through the Panama Canal into the
Caribbean and eventually to its
destination on the East Coast sometimes
who know something could happen that
would be simultaneously great for the
Caribbean ports but terrible for the
Panama Canal you see two countries to
the north of Panama is Nicaragua by
linking both the Atlantic and the
Pacific to the large Lake Nicaragua one
could have another connection between
the oceans there has been a long history
of attempts to build this canal most
recently in the past decade with a
failed scheme by a Chinese billionaire
given that this failure was recent there
are no current construction plans
but at least somewhere the world is
going to need more canal capacity
between the Pacific and the Atlantic the
shipping industry is growing at a solid
rate of about five percent annually and
the Panama Canal can only expand so much
one issue is that the Panama Canal could
literally run out of water you see each
time the canals locks open millions of
gallons of water flow out and downstream
usually this is not a problem because
the lake upstream has enough water but
sometimes during periods of reduced
rainfall there just won't be enough
water to both release the amount needed
to operate the locks and keep the lake
at a deep enough level for the larger
ships to transit at these times which
included much of spring 2019 the canal
will have to place restrictions on how
much weight cargo ships can carry as
this will affect how deep they sit in
the water they've attempted to limit the
effects of this by installing systems to
recapture some of the water used to
operate the locks and there are also
potential plans to build an additional
upstream dam to create an additional
reservoir but these problems are only
expected to worsen as climate change
exacerbates the severity of droughts in
the region all told what happens in
Panama affects the world if a drought in
Panama restricts the throughput of the
canal the world economy will feel it
that's because shipping is what connects
the world's economy and the Panama Canal
is one of the most important connectors
in shipping the canal effectively brings
the economies on one side closer to
those on the other and so no matter what
happens it will continue to serve as the
world's shortcut now one of the things
that those working at the Panama Canal
need to understand is how water works as
in how weather works how the water cycle
works how ties work all of these things
are also though concepts that you can
learn about new brilliant physics of the
everyday course brilliant is the best
place to learn complex things such as
physics or really any field of math and
science not only do they have all their
fantastically designed courses they also
have in the goal of helping you get a
little smarter every single day a series
of daily challenges in just five minutes
while you're waiting for the subway the
toaster the doctor or whatever you can
challenge yourself with one of these and
then if it piques your interest each is
linked to one of their full-length
courses as
well you can try brilliant and support
the channel by signing up for free at
brilliance dot org slash Wendover also
though the first 200 people that go to
that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription